en attendant on se rafraîchit comme on
peut en matinée les nuits tropicales
dont le mercure dépasse les 20 degrés
Celsius sont de plus en plus communes à
Montréal les étés c'était assez élevés
comme température ça frôlé le 30 degrés
dans la où on dormait depuis c'était
chaud la métropole québécoise vivait en
moyenne 8 tropicales par été entre 1966
et 2005 mais au cours des 30 prochaines
années les Montréalais devraient
traverser 19 nuits chaudes par été puis
28 dans l'horizon 2051 à 2080 et la
santé en paix le prix les températures
nocturnes sont super importantes pour
faire diminuer la température dans les
logements si ces températures-là
arrivent pas à descendre on fait le
corps de la difficulté à s'adapter c'est
là que proviennent après ça les
problèmes de santé dus au vagues de
chaleur les nuits chaudes réduisent la
durée du sommeil confirme une étude
danoise publiée dans la revue one heart
club
on sait que les gens qui dorment moins
bien ont un vieillissement de tous les
organes un peu plus prématurées chaque
personne perd environ 40 heures de
sommeil par année en raison de la
chaleur nocturne l'accumulation de la
fatigue crée un déficit de sommeil
difficile à récupérer le sommeil on en a
besoin on peut faire des crises en bois
ça va augmenter l'angoisse les
dépressions tout ça donc oui c'est quand
même important donc oui ça aura des
impacts au niveau de la santé mentale et
de la santé physique c'est sûr autre
constat cuisant les vagues de chaleur a
plus de 30 degrés Celsius seront de plus
en plus longues selon les projections de
l'Atlas climatique du Canada ces vagues
durant moyen de 5 jours présentement
mais elle devrait s'étendre sur huit
jours entre 2050 et 2100 si les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
augmentent au rythme actuel ici
Jean-Philippe news Radio-Canada Montréal